زاد بظهورها اطل واسحب مرتين في اقل من 48
ساعه ليست عادت بوتن على الاقل منذ بدايه
الحرب لديه الكثير ليقوله عدا السخريه من
منظومه فاتريه والكثير من الحماس على ما
يبدون يخطط الحرب الجديده لكن قبل الحديث
عن مرحله الحرب المقبله لنعود قليلا الى
صباح الرابع والعشرين من فبراير انفجارات
عنيفه تهزوا اكياف وادسه
تلاها هجوم روسيا شامل على اربعه محاور
لننظر الى الخريطه مشاهدينا
خيرسون ودوم بس الجزء الاهم من القوات
هاجم انطلاقا من اراضي بيلاروسيا بهدف
تطبيق كياب خطه روسيه كانت مكشوفه قبل
تنفيذها مطار جاستنميل وافتحوا السر
وبالفعل نجحت القوات الروسيه في الاستيلاء
عليه لكن تدميرك للجسور افشل الخطه موسكو
حاولت لاسابيع قبل ان تنسحب من محوري كيب
وسومي الخطوه التاليه كانت تركيز على
تومدم باس لكن افقد ذلك روسيا المبادره في
بقيه المناطق وبصول قوات اوكرانيه مدربه
في دول النيته ومجهزه باسلحه ومتطوره
انسحبت روسيا من اقليم خاركيب ثم من لمان
في خرسون ثلاثه لم يقبلها الروس
نيته في الاكتفاء بالدفاع طيله الشتاء
كانت حيله بنظر الاوكرانيين وراء هذه
الحواجز الاسمنتيه يستعد الجيش الروسي
اللي يشله من خلال الاسابيع الستات
المقبله الاستخبارات السوريه اكدت اذن
تحضيره
itang
في ظل تاكيداتي موسكو على تكبير اوكرانيا
خسائر كبيره في جبهه باخمود التقارير
تتحدث عن تغيير روسيا لتكتيكاتها هناك
اولا عبر زياده تعزيزات العسكريه من معدات
الثقيله ومدرعات
وزياده عدد القوات الروسيه هناك وبالاخص
قوات فاكنر الخاصه ثانيا العامليات
المستمره للمجموعات الصغيره من المشاهد في
جبهه واسعه وبدعم من المركبات المدرعه
لكنما اقلق اوكرانيا هو وجود القوات
الروسيه في بيلاروسيا واجراءها لتدريبات
تكتيكيه مكثفه بعد وصولها الى هناك لتشكيل
مجموعات اقليميه مشتركه وهو ما يعني
امكانيه وجود مخطط للهجوم على كيف من جبهه
المسك التي زارها بوتر مؤخرا لكن هذه
التقارير نفاها الكريملين ماذا عن كيف
هناك
العسكريه اقصى درجات الحذر وتجهز نفسها
لكافه السيناريوهان بدات كيف تشييد الجدار
فاصلا على الحدود الاوكرانيه البيلاروسيا
وابعته باسلاك شائكه ثم خنادق وقامت بزرع
الالغام على كامل الحدود كما عززتني من
قوات امن الحدود وفصائل الجيش الاوكرانيه
المختلفه كما ارسلت اللواء الثامنه
والخمسين الى مثلث الحدود الاوكرانيه
الروسيه الروسيه وذلك على الرغم من ان
القياده العسكريه ترى ان الروس يركزون
جهودهم في دونيس وهو ما سيعيق فتحهم لجبهه
جديده في الوقت
كما ذكر مراسلنا لا تاكيد رسمي حول هجوم
الشامل تتفق واشنطن لا ادله ولا مؤشرات
وبوتن لن يغامر بشعبيتهم مجددا قبل
الاستعداد الجيد اهميه العاصمه لا تسمح
بالمجازفه مره اخرى
قبل العوده لمحور كياب الجيش الروسي ان
يحتاج المزيد من الوقت لتجميع قوته وتعويض
خسائره
في سنوات كامله لهندسه هجومها الاول على
كلاب وللمفارقه سبقتهم منورات مع عبد الله
روسيا
الهجوم بالفشل والرغم ان وقتها لم تكن
اوكرانيا بقوه واستعداد ما هي عليه اليوم
هنا ياتي اختيار التواجد العسكري الروسي
في بيلاروسيا والهدف صاحب جزء من القوات
الاوكرانيه بعيدا عن خط المواجهه 900 كيلو
متر من الحدود مع الجاره الشماليه بناء
التحصينات حراسه الحدود يستنزف قدرات كيا
خيار اخر روسيا نقلت صواريخ كنغال الى
بيلاروسيا مدى الصواريخ الروسيه يصل الى
كيا فلاحه هنا لمطارات بيلاروسيا وتبدو
رساله اكثر منها خيار من روسيا مشاركه في
الحرب الحليب المتبقي لروسيا تفصله عن
الحدود 300 كم فقط
وذخيره للمدفعيه دعم لافت مقارنه بجيشها
المتواضع 50 الف جنديه مع امكانيه تعبئه
500 الف جندي اذا اضفنا ذلك للاقتراح
الروسي الاخير بزياده حجم الجيش بثلاثين
في المئه نتحدث عن مليون و500,000 جندي
هذا السيناريو بالطبع يخيب ثياب
غير ان تجهيز هذه القوات تحدي اخر المشكله
حلت ولو الجزئيا وهذه نظره اقرب على
اولويات الصناعه الروسيه هي كفيله بكشف
اهداف المرحله المقبله
انتاجي الدبابات تحديدا سلاح الهجنيا
الرئيسي في العقيده الروسيه
2500 دبابه من طراز ياتي 90 ام حديثه باتت
ابي حوزه الجنود وثلاثه الاف دبابه اخرى
يسرى تحديثها